(Casting)
"He just goes 'Top Die' and then he gets a solo kill."
Jung “Impact” Eon-yeong was born in March 1995 in South Korea and was
an early adopter to League of Legends, playing on the North American server before the Korean
one was released.
But once it was released in December 2011, his talent attracted attention.
He first joined Xenics Storm as a support player in 2012 where he helped them qualify
for the upcoming OGN spring season.
Xenics made a deep run in that inaugural Champions tournament, losing an extremely close semifinal
to MiG Frost.
(Casting)
They won the third place match against OP, finishing their first season in third,
and regrouped for summer.
But after Storm’s run in the summer ended in the quarterfinals, Impact entered a period
of roster turbulence.
He left Xenics to play for Tempest, but that roster was eventually acquired by Xenics.
But by February 2013, Impact left the org for good and found a new team.
Impact found a place on SK Telecom T12’s newly-formed roster.
And having switched to top lane near the end of his time with Xenics, he’d stay in that
role with SKT.
It was clear almost immediately that SKT had something special in that roster.
(Casting)
Playing alongside bengi, Faker, Piglet and PoohManDu, SKT T12 placed third in the spring
but came into their own by the time summer started.
And, in a dazzling final outside the Jamsil Olympic Stadium in Seoul in August 2013, Impact
Impact won his first OGN title.
(Casting)
Impact played well in that series, showing that he was a top-level player in his position.
But his performance was somewhat obscured by one of his teammates’ growing shadow.
(Casting)
With rivals KT Rolster Bullets missing out on the World Championship that year, Impact
and SK Telecom T1 K looked like the strongest Korean team headed to the year’s biggest tournament.
SKT entered the group stage ready to assert their dominance.
But they were surprised by the quality of teams that they faced early on.
And when they dropped a group stage game to China’s OMG, SKT, the strongest team
heading into the tournament, realized that they needed to get serious.
That this was no vacation.
SKT exited the group stage 7-1 and, in the quarterfinals, they matched up against one
of four teams seeded directly into the bracket:
The Gamania Bears.
They dispatched them, 2-0.
(Casting)
So far, SKT had only dropped one game throughout the tournament.
But they faced a serious obstacle in semifinals.
Najin Sword.
The winners of Champions Winter 2012-2013, Najin qualified directly for the quarterfinals
at Worlds, so by the time SKT sat down to face them, they had little recent information on them.
And perhaps because of that unfamiliarity, it was a close series from the get-go,
"That leaves us at 2-2 now. We're gonna go into the last game, it's anyones."
SKT got off to an early lead thanks to superior laning and an edge in objectives,
but Najin continued to apply pressure with their pick-focused comp.
In the end, SKT’s superior teamfighting was too much for Najin, and they ended the
game quickly off the back of one clean fight.
(Casting)
It was the first time since the Korean summer final that SKT had really been tested.
For a roster with young players, many in their first year of competitive play, they were
able to stay calm and composed.
And they dismantled Najin in the clutch.
"When they win they win so quickly."
"That was one team fight. Into game over for SKT."
There was one series left between Impact, SKT and history.
One stage.
And it would be one of esports’ biggest
to date.
Though Season 2’s World Championship had been one of the biggest esports events held
in the West ever at the time, Season 3’s offering was on a completely different scale.
And it was in a packed Staples Centre, to the roar of thousands of fans, that Impact
and his team played for an engraving on the Summoner’s Cup.
Though Impact was no stranger to playing in front of large crowds, this would be his biggest
so far.
And in the lead-up to the finals, SKT’s players were candid about some nerves related
to the big series.
Their opponents in the final were Royal Club, a Chinese team that bulldozed OMG and Fnatic
on their way to the finals.
The team’s big personalities and Tabe’s English interviews quickly made them a fan favorite.
But it wasn’t just popular perception, Royal’s clean dismantling of OMG and Fnatic
the two other teams to go 7-1 in groups convinced many analysts of their strength.
"I'm going with Royal"
"I'm going to have to go ahead and choose Royal as well."
"Royal all the way."
(Casting)
After going up 2-0 against Royal, SKT looked set to sweep the series.
As far as Impact was concerned, once they locked in Jax, one of his signature picks,
the tournament was his.
(Casting)
In the end Worlds 2013 belonged to Korea.
It belonged to SKT.
It belonged to Impact.
For Impact, and the rest of SKT, standing on that stage and hoisting that trophy
was the culmination of their careers so far.
But they wanted more.
And they got it.
SKT went undefeated in the group stage of Champions winter 2013-2014.
They swept Samsung Blue in the quarterfinals.
They swept the KT Rolster Bullets in the semifinals.
Then, they swept Samsung Ozone in the finals.
15-0, in six series.
It’s still the only perfect season in the history of Korean League.
SKT were on top of the world.
But it was the last time Impact would taste
success in Korea.
2014 was a slump year for SKT.
Although 2013 had been all about the mechanical prowess of SKT’s stars, two new rosters
had begun to rise to prominence, ones with the mechanics and teamplay to surpass SKT.
Samsung Blue and Samsung Ozone (later Samsung White) were two of the strongest rosters in
the world in 2014.
And the latter knocked SKT out of Champions Spring and Summer in the quarterfinals both times.
Then, SKT missed out on Worlds after losing to a surging Najin White Shield in the Regional Finals.
SKT didn’t even get a chance to defend their
World Championship.
Fans of the team had begun to see some of the players as dead weight.
Faker was still a god, but his teammates couldn’t keep up.
And though Impact played well in in the series against White Shield, there was a clear sense
that changes needed to be made.
At the same time, Riot Korea announced that they would be removing sisters teams for the
2015 season.
And, as some teams consolidated their rosters there was also a huge surge of players leaving
Korea, as stars from League’s top region sought glory and money abroad.
Impact was one of them.
According to reports at the time, Impact chose to leave the roster, and he’s said that
he was ready for something new.
He joined Team Impulse, and got off to a decent start with his new team, finishing the regular
season in fourth place with an 11-7 record.
They lost to Team SoloMid in the playoff semifinals, then to Team Liquid in the third-place match
to finish the Spring in fourth.
Impulse played high-kill, entertaining games, often with off-meta picks like Yasuo, Fizz and Lee Sin.
But even as he embraced and enabled his team’s chaotic playstyle, Impact was a stable force
in the top lane.
(Casting)
For the first time in his career, he was not overshadowed by mechanical prodigies.
Instead, he was the veteran presence among a group of relatively inexperienced players.
Though he was still working on English, Impact had quietly become more than just one of the
mechanically strongest tops in NA.
By the end of summer he was also learning to put his over-confident past behind him
and become a leader.
"At first it's kind of intimidating. But I do have a lot of respect for him. He has a lot of knowledge.
He's really patient with the game. So it's been quite a big learning experience for me."
And heading into playoffs in Summer 2015, TiP
were a legitimate contender.
They finished the regular season in third place at 12-6.
Their wild and unpredictable style had allowed them to take wins off of teams trying for
a more standard style, and their powerful solo lanes in Impact and XiaoWeiXiao were a force.
(Casting)
But, after XiaoWeiXiao was banned due to Elo boosting, Impulse’s unpredictable style
wasn’t enough.
They lost to CLG in the semifinals and Team Liquid in the third-place match.
Impulse finished fourth again.
It was enough to earn Impact and company a
spot in the Regional Gauntlet.
For Impact, it was a chance for him to make it back to Worlds.
To stand on that stage one more time.
And it started off well.
But after a reverse sweep at the hands of Cloud9 — who were on their way to a miraculous
run to Worlds — Impulse finished short of a spot on the world stage.
For Impact, it was the second time in a row he’d been eliminated in the Gauntlet,
falling just shy of a Worlds berth.
Impact joined a new team, NRG Esports in November.
But despite a relatively strong start to the spilt, NRG failed to make much of a splash,
and were eliminated in the quarterfinals.
Though Impact had earned the respect of North American fans, he had yet to really prove himself.
He might have been seen as one of NA’s strongest top laners, but he had yet to play for one
of NA’s strongest teams.
It was time for another change.
It was on Cloud9 that Impact cemented himself as one of the strongest top laners in the region.
And Impact’s dominant laning helped to coin a new phrase.
“He just goes 'Top Die' and then he gets a solo kill, so I don't know he's really good.”
And, throughout the end of the split, Impact was making waves again
for stellar individual plays with the team,
prompting analysts and players to herald him as the region’s best top laner.
This time, Impact wasn’t eliminated early in playoffs and Cloud9 made it to the finals.
The series was close
(Casting)
but in the end, TSM was able to clutch the series out.
This time, after defeating Team EnVyUs and Immortals in the Regional Gauntlet, Impact
was able to secure a spot at the World Championship, his first time back at the game’s biggest
stage since he won it in 2013.
Cloud9 landed in a rough group at Worlds 2016, facing off against SK Telecom T1, I May and
Flash Wolves.
With SKT a clear favorite to make it out of the group, Cloud9 were expected to struggle
to find the second seed.
This was especially true against the Taiwanese players on Flash Wolves,
who had built up a formidable reputation at international events.
But the group stage draw meant something else for Impact: he would face off against his
old teammates, his old coach.
He would play against the organization that made his career.
(Casting)
In the end, SKT beat Cloud9 in both their group stage games,
But, thanks to some struggles from Flash Wolves and consistent play on Cloud9’s part,
(Casting)
The NA team was able to secure the second seed
to quarterfinals with a 3-3 record.
In quarterfinals, Cloud9 faced off against eventual finalists Samsung Galaxy
(Casting)
and were dismantled 3-0.
Cloud9 were not expected to win.
They went further than any other NA team at the tournament.
But against one of the best teams in the world, they couldn’t hold up.
"Look at back at how they got here and Impact was playing so good in the Top lane and teams made sure
to shut that down as much as they could."
"And it definitely seemed like that's what Cloud9 was lacking and the fact that Impact couldn't get going
again, not saying it's his fault, teams made sure that Impact couldn't get going again."
It might have been a decent performance for NA on the international stage, but for Impact
it was another year without an NA LCS title, and another year without any notable results
on the international stage.
In Spring 2017, Cloud9 came close again.
They placed second in the regular season, with Impact taking 11 “player of the game
awards,” tied for second with Hauntzer, just behind Dardoch’s 12.
But after making their way to another finals against TSM, they fell in a close 3-2 series
to miss out on MSI.
And in the summer split, Cloud9 faltered.
"Heartbreak for Cloud9 this is a game that Cloud9 had a 10 thousand gold lead and three dead inhibitors.
And they full built Tristana, and they failed to attack Nexus turrets.
To play it right to close the game, their tanks got caught out shoved into the fight."
Yet again, TSM hoisted the trophy while Cloud9 were forced to play in the Regional Finals
for a shot at Worlds.
(Casting)
This time, Cloud9 had to make it through the Play-In Stage, where they swept their group
and qualifier match without dropping
a game.
(Casting)
But once they qualified for the main event, Impact and the rest of Cloud9 faced stiff competition.
With shades of 2016, they once again had to face SKT, along with tough international teams
in EDward Gaming and ahq e-Sports Club.
Once again, Cloud9 made it out with a 3-3 record as the second seed.
Once again they were the only NA team to advance to the Top 8.
This time, though, Cloud9 wouldn’t be facing off against a top Korean team.
They were seeded against World Elite, a Chinese roster that had showed strong results in groups,
but who looked mortal.
Cloud9 had a fighting chance.
And they knew it.
The series went back and forth, with everything coming down to a pivotal Game 5.
(Casting)
But WE was able to push a mid game lead to a huge gold advantage, and in the end Cloud9
couldn’t clutch the series.
(Casting)
For Impact, it was the end of his third year in NA, and after two quarterfinal exits at
Worlds and too many almosts in the NA LCS, it was clear that something had to change.
The end of 2017 signaled a new, franchised era in North America and with big money flowing
into the scene, there was a huge turnover in rosters.
Orgs vied for top talent to secure the best possible franchised team for themselves,
and after three splits with Cloud9, Impact moved to a new roster.
Team Liquid attracted a lot of attention heading into the Spring Split.
Impact joined TL alongside former-CLG core Xmithie, Pobelter and Doublelift
and Korean support Olleh.
It was a roster that boasted proven synergy and very strong lanes.
People expected Team Liquid to dominate.
"Yeah this roster was basically built to win, that's why I joined it."
The regular season saw some stumbles,
"And you can see Impact. Devastated."
and despite a strong start, by the end of the split Team Liquid were caught in a convoluted
tie near the top of the standings.
They entered playoffs in quarterfinals, with a lot of questions about their play.
But those questions were dismissed almost immediately.
(Casting)
All season long it was clear that Team Liquid had the talent to win.
They’d assembled a roster stacked with individual
talent.
But until playoffs, they’d been unable to capitalize on their potential.
And they peaked at the right time.
(Casting)
In the end only one team stood between Liquid and the NA LCS trophy.
100 Thieves.
Liquid were able to ride the momentum.
(Casting)
And the rest of the series was about one team. And one team only.
Liquid dominated the rest of finals, and as the confetti rained down on them, Impact was elated.
After more than three years in North America, and so many close-but-not-quites,
the win was Impact’s first title since Champions
Winter 2013-14.
In the four and a half years since then, he’d moved across the world, developed his skills,
become a leader, learned a new language and made many, many top laners die.
His peers in the NA LCS had come to revere him as one of the best tops to ever play in the region.
there’s no question that Impact has already cemented his place in League’s history books.
Impact has evolved from a brash, young player to a mature,
veteran presence who’s capable of fitting into any team.
But he’d never been able to hoist that trophy.
Never conquered his region. But on that hot day in Florida, Impact was back on top.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.